In this section, we're going to walk through the process of creating the base Blueprint
and adding our basic components.
Our Blueprint will serve as a self-contained actor that can be used multiple times within
our levels, with each Blueprint instance able to trigger a separate sequence.
Any updates we make to the logic will occur on the single Blueprint actor and propagate
to every instance within our levels.
Let's hop over to the level and start this process.
So for this section, we're going to want to have our 305 Start Map open, which you can
find in the Content Courses Sequence 30500 Maps folder.
Now with this open, I'm going to go back down to my Content Browser and in my BP folder,
under our Sequence 305 folder, I'm going to create a new Blueprint actor.
Now before we do that, I want to make a quick note about the two Blueprints that
you see within this folder.
The BP Sequence TriggerBox EX, for example, is what we're going to be building for this class.
This is our basic logic required to activate our sequences.
The BP Sequence TriggerBox Final is the full-up, robust Blueprint class that is included
in the 905 maps, and that contains all of the additional logic for adding a UMG widget
on screen.
Inherently, both have the same core functionality, but the Sequence TriggerBox Final is what
we will showcase at the end of the class.
Alright, so within our BP folder, I'm going to right-click, go up to Blueprint, and
add a Blueprint class.
Now you can, this is the same one in the basic asset, or you can create one under
Blueprint, both are the same.
We'll create a Blueprint class, and we're going to create, I'll move this over here,
an actor.
So with this, we'll call this BP, for Blueprint, underscore, SEQ for Sequence, and we'll
call this TriggerBox, and then I'm just going to write Example.
But choose whatever you want to, the name isn't as particular, just make sure you
know which one you're building.
Alright, we'll double-click this.
This will open up our Blueprint Editor window.
I'm going to expand my Details out and pin it, because we will be referencing some
of these later.
And now let's start building the logic within this Blueprint.
So the first thing I'm going to do is go over to my Components tab, click Add, and
I'm just going to start typing Collision, C-O-L-L-I, and we're going to add a Box
Collision.
You'll see that it adds it within the middle here, we'll press F to frame, there
we go.
And two changes that I want to make, just so I can see this on screen, are the Box
Extent, and then we're actually going to change our color.
So under Box Extent, I'm going to change this to 200 by 200 by 200.
And this will just change the overall size of the volume, so that when the player's
collision intersects with it, that it will trigger whatever logic we're going
to build later.
Alright, and then I'm just going to expand out Advanced and shape color, again feel
free to change this to whatever you want, I'm going to do something like a hot
pink, and then change my line thickness to maybe say something like 10, 5, whatever
you want.
Press Escape here, we'll go ahead and compile, and save, and now we have the base
logic for our blueprint that we're going to build the code on.